und jetzt kommen wir zu einer geschichte
die wirklich schockiert
john de soll sein baby so lang schüttelt
haben ist es tot ist der tatort dieses
mehrfamilienhaus im
nordrhein-westfälischen oerlinghausen
hier musste der dreimonatige lex wohl
sterben weil der vater das geld von der
lebensversicherung des kindes kassieren
wollte insgesamt 350.000 euro
der polizei erklärte john de damals
lexus verletzungen seien durch einen
unfall passiert glauben wollte ihm
allerdings dass niemand nur seine frau
die stand und steht weiterhin zu ihrem
mann
ihm wird jetzt der prozess gemacht und
diesem prozess beobachtet für uns markus
brekenkamp markus wie verlief denn der
erste prozesstag heute ja der erste
prozesstag war emotional
der vater hatte ihr zunächst mal seine
unschuld beteuert ich dann als
liebevollen fürsorglichen vater
dargestellt der selbst in der
schwangerschaft zu jeder
vorsorgeuntersuchung mitgehen und dann
später um seiner frau die fortsetzung
ihrer ausbildung zu ermöglichen
selbst in elternzeit ging und das kind
zu hause betreut in diesem zusammenhang
schilderte er dann zwei unfälle die
beide in der anklage mit drin stehen
einmal oder dem in oberarm gebrochen da
hatte der der vater die erklärung dass
er das kind auf dem arm hatte über eine
teppich kannte gestolpert sei und dann
im reflex zugedrückt hätte oben am
oberarm
das zweite der zweite vorfall war dann
der der zuletzt deutlich für das kind
ausging
dort soll er sich mit dem kind im arm
auf einen sessel fallen lassen und dann
sei das kind mit dem kopf gegen eine
fensterbrett kannte gestoßen prozess
beobachtungen von markus brekenkamp in
detmold ganz herzlichen dank
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren